former senator Christopher Dodd and
Senator Bob Casey found disparities in
the well-being of America's children
first focus and Save the Children
released the report here in Washington
among those you'll hear from Save the
Children artist ambassador and actress
Jennifer Garner come I want to see this
on yeah nope good how's it on there we
go all right thank you all for coming
here today and joining first focus and
save the children discuss America's
report card 2012 I'm Bruce Leslie
president first focus we are national
bipartisan advocacy group dedicated to
making children and families a priority
and federal policy and budget decisions
first and foremost I want to thank
Senator Chris Dodd and Senator Bob Casey
for joining us today they were the
inspiration and for this this effort
they've also been tireless champions on
behalf of our nation's children for
years and years I'm sir Sir dot in his
36 years on the hill and I'll talk a
little bit about more about him in a
minute but for both of them have been
great champions for children over the
years I also want to thank our key
partner on this report Save the Children
and March Shriver for being strong
partners in the creation of of this
whole effort and for everything related
to the report and also Jennifer Garner
who is here today with us and we really
appreciate that and for her fantastic
work to save the children and for being
such a strong advocate for children all
our nation's children across the country
um first focus and say the children
could not have done this report also
without the help of the Americas report
card advisory board a panel of experts
across many fields who are instrumental
in helping to highlight aspects an
American child's life that are the
strongest indicators of their well-being
in
chance for a bright future some of them
are here today and I'll introduce them a
little bit later I'm America's report
card stem from a series of hearings on
the state of America's child from june
to november 2010 by sled by Senator Dodd
then chairman of the US Senate
Subcommittee on children and families of
these hearings led to a subcommittee
report that provided a snapshot of the
well-being of america american children
based on family economic security
education and child health and provided
policy recommendations to improve
outcomes in these areas following the
release of the state of American child
report Senator Dodd and Senator Bob
Casey called on first focus and saved
the children to create a periodic report
card too broad a holistic picture of
children's unmet needs in America and
policy suggestions on how to meet those
needs so one of things that we in walk
thinking about this report is we prayed
children all the time I have four kids
and I went to back to school nights in
the past few few weeks and I figured out
that my kids get great at about 300
times a year whether it's tests quizzes
homework assignments plus all the
testing that are required by national
policy so you know it's no child left
behind etc so 300 times we assess kids a
year and so what we thought about here
was what how about how about how we all
as a nation are doing on kids so what's
what's our report on how we're fairing
for kids so this is the chance to turn
that around and grade ourselves copies
of the report are available as you all
know and also on our website our grades
are not and assessing a particular
institution or entity we are not grading
governor's or state legislators or even
Congress in the administration instead
we're grading the nation as a whole so
it's society business families
communities and how we measure up
compared with other nations on the
expectations we should have for
ourselves this is a call to action that
we all must be child advocates and we
can muster
better by our children I'd like to first
introduce Senator Chris Dodd the
inspiration behind report just a few
words about him sir dad had a an amazing
thirty-six year career on Capitol Hill
working and n I'll say this I think
you'll agree i'm working tirelessly to
protect the rights well-being and health
of our nation's children in the child
advocacy world when i started he was the
go-to guy on any issue in any community
so in the children's community so
whether was child care child health
child abuse and neglect education
whatever the issue was people always
were we should talk to Senator Dodd
staff first and foremost in 1983 Sarah
co-founded the first children's caucus
and also from his position as chairman
of the children family subcommittee he
passed laws relating to all the issues i
mentioned child care Family Medical
Leave education child health and child
abuse prevention so I want to thank
sadad for all that but also for
inspiring this report and I turn it over
to you
well good morning and it's wonderful to
see such a great turnout this morning to
be a part of this news in this report
card and I'm delighted to be with you
Bruce and I thank very much first focus
for their work as well as save the
children that I've been pleased to be
associated with for many many meters and
proud of the fact that they're located
in Connecticut as well we like to take
some local parochial prior to the fact
they're in in our state and to Bob Casey
my former colleague and dear friend from
Pennsylvania who was just done a
tremendous job brings a wonderful
commitment in history deeply committed
to the issue of children and families to
the the United States Congress so it's a
an honor to be with them and Jennifer we
thank you immensely you've lent yours
celebrity but also your your mind and
your commitment to these issues and we
thank you immensely for the work you do
and issues that obviously being a mother
herself with young children and and I'm
a despite what the gray hair here is a
father of very young children I have a I
dropped my 11 year old and seven year
old at the public school in the district
of columbia this morning it was to say
it was the only person I knew that got
mail from AARP and diaper services I
sort of a broad reach when it comes to
up these issues so I'm honored to be in
the presence of marking and Bob and
bruising and Jennifer and thank all of
them for the tremendous work they do and
for the effort that's been put into this
particular effort on to giving us as a
nation the ability to make judgments and
as we do it in so many areas we keep
records of how people have batting
averages today the city will be
celebrating in a sense its first return
to to Major League Baseball finals in
Washington and yet every morning you can
read how players are doing this morning
is already telling us how the stock
market is doing within 10 minutes of its
opening we have ability to judge how its
numbers compared to yesterday and a week
ago a month ago there are any number of
examples how we keep records of how
we're doing what we doing better we
doing worse and yet we have failed in my
view over the years to really keep the
same kind of calibration about how we're
doing on the most important constituency
all of us acknowledge and admit and that
is our children
how are they doing in our country and
how are they doing compared to others
around the world and are we doing a
better job are we celebrating enough the
victories that have been made over the
years and improving the quality of life
for children and if not why aren't we
doing better in certain areas so this
was an idea that's been a long time
coming to be able to have that once a
year to be able to gather together and
say how are we doing is a country and
again I've never met anybody in public
or private life that didn't believe the
most important issues we face as a
country was to see to it we leave a
nation and better shape than when we
inherited it and that obviously depend
on what happens to the young people
coming along who will be the part of
this audience one day standing at these
podiums engaged in the meaningful debate
life of art of our nation so I begin by
thanking all of you my former colleague
as I said Bob and others who've been
involved and cared deeply about this
issue of all the issues of all the
issues that i worked on in my 30 years
as a member the United States Senate and
36 of the Congress nothing meant more to
me as a public official as a public
servant than trying to help children and
their families across this country from
almost the very first day I arrived in
the United States Senate more than 30
years ago I began working on these
issues and I appreciate Bruce making
reference this morning to the fact that
on 1983 30 years ago this year another
freshman senator from Pennsylvania by
the name of Arlen Specter and I formed
together the first children's caucus in
the United States Senate and we began
holding rump hearings all over the
country on children's health on child
abuse after school programs and a number
of issues that affected children every
single day we didn't have a formal
status we weren't a legitimate committee
of the Congress but we decided to use
our offices to come together and try to
bring some attention to these issues
Orrin Hatch and I wrote the first child
care legislation since World War two
putting some resources of the public
government to make it available for
working families to be able to have a
safe and secure place where their
children could be is they went off to
work and tried to provide for their
family needs and after seven years my
colleagues dan coats of Indiana kit bond
to Missouri Ted Kennedy and others we
were finally able to pass
the Family and Medical Leave Act and in
February of 1993 the very first act that
he did as a president of United States
Bill Clinton signed into law the Family
and Medical Leave Act Rick Santorum and
I who Pennsylvania wrote the legislation
dealing with autism Lamar Alexander and
I worked on allergy legislation together
premature births infant screening
after-school programs with Mike DeWine
point I want to make can I mention these
names to you is because it wasn't that
long ago that there were Republicans and
Democrats who worked together on these
issues here and it ought to be that way
again this is not a partisan battle in a
sense who cares about children who's
willing to stand up and come together
there's ought not to be an issue between
blacks bullet blue states in red states
but rather people who decide they want
to make a difference in the lives of
children so we made a great deal of
progress i might point out on many of
these issues the face children their
families during those years that i
served in the united states congress and
as i prepared to leave the Senate after
announcing my retirement to a 2010 I
decided to take a look back on the work
that have been done and to determine
what would still be needed in order for
children and their families to do better
so we held a number of hearings which
Bob Casey played an integral part during
that year of 2010 during my last year in
the Congress going back and reviewing
what had occurred to children over the
years we found that despite the programs
that are given millions of Americans the
chance to become a part of the middle
class one out of every four children in
the United States was living in poverty
and even though test scores and school
standards have been improving only about
half of fourth eighth and twelfth
graders and our country were able to
read and do math at the appropriate
level those hearings show that despite
the good progress that we have made more
and more much more needed to be done for
our nation's children so in December of
2010 a month before I left office I
stood behind a podium not unlike this
one with Mark and Bob and Bruce to
announce the establishment of an annual
report card on the state of America's
children that wrist report card would
examine the lives of children is
is already pointed out in a holistic
fashion and determine in what areas we
needed to be doing a better job a little
less than two years later it's a
pleasure for me to be back with these
dedicated people that saved the children
at first focus with Jennifer Garner and
others to give this America's report
card for 2012 to all of you gathered
here today I'll leave it to mark and to
adult as to this morning to go into the
details of the report's findings but I
want to just take a moment if I can to
talk a little bit about my own personal
views on its conclusion and what I think
we need where we need to go over the
last two decades strong progress has
been made in a number of areas related
to children's well-being and we need to
celebrate those victories and those
improvements too often at moments like
this we just recite the litany of things
that are wrong things have gotten better
at number of areas with children and we
need to talk about that as well today
thanks to programs like the Children's
Health Insurance Program Medicaid the
Affordable Care Act ninety percent of
children are covered by some form of
health insurance that is great news
that's a vast improvement education
initiatives like the race to the top
early education challenge have improved
access to early childhood education
programs for low-income children in our
country a total of five hundred million
dollars was awarded to schools in the
last few months through this competitive
grant program that is good news it needs
to be celebrated and the overall dropout
rates among our nation's students have
declined slightly while test scores have
risen slightly as well showing
improvements in all levels of education
but even with these positive trends the
report shows that as a nation we need to
do more much more if we're going to have
a country that's stronger and children
who are leading better lives despite the
continued economic recovery families are
still feeling the effects of the 2008
financial crisis I'm stating the obvious
obviously with one in five children
living below the poverty line the child
poverty rate as the highest level that's
been in two decades states are feeling
ever-growing constraints on their
budgets as many of you are aware
and despite the general belief that we
need to provide for the needs of our
children many of these states have
targeted programs for funding cuts that
are so vital to the well-being of our
children consider this for the second
school year in a row state funding for
preschool programs have been cut by
nearly 60 million dollars and in order
to make up for budget shortfalls many
states are scaling back funding for
childcare assistance programs despite
the benefits that these programs provide
for millions of America's children and
though we've made progress in reducing
the rate of infant mortality consider
this if you will this morning the United
States still ranks 29th in the world and
infant deaths among industrialized
nations 29 in terms of infant mortality
regardless of your political persuasion
your ideological beliefs that's tistic
statistic alone ought to be a rallying
cry for all Americans to do a better job
and seeing that our nation's children
have a chance at life as they enter this
world it is up to us to ensure that the
challenge are facing America's children
are addressed children can't appear on
cable talk shows they can't contribute
to political campaigns they can't vote
obviously they can only count on us it
is our political if you will the
political discussion that occurring in
these days where the loudest voices as
all of us know are heard in these
debates this November I'd ask everyone
to be casting a ballot for candidates
and for children who will be at first I
hope in their minds and after the
election no matter who wins or what
Kennedy prevails a party does to see to
it that these people are elected to
office remain accountable to the
promises made during this season these
are issues that can there are solvable
in our nation and if we choose to put
America's children at the forefront of
our national agenda we choose to tackle
these issues head-on by investing in our
nation's youth then we can overcome
these challenges and give not only our
children the brighter future they
deserve we'll give our country the
brighter future that it deserves as well
and so I want to thank all of you again
for being a part of this those who
helped with this report together the
organizations that have come to
and as I look out in the audience
audience I see a number of people who
served on my Senate children's committee
staff over the years and I'd be remiss
if I didn't thank them for the
tremendous job they did on behalf of
America's children their families and
again the you Bob I thank you meant for
the job that you're doing in this issues
you're doing a becoming a great great
champion for children the Jennifer we
thank you for all your wonderful efforts
and being here today to be a part of
this and Bruce obviously first focus is
important and lastly mark my dear friend
who have known almost all his life and
it's so proud of the work he does and
the work that saved the children does
both internationally here at home it's a
great great organization i'm deeply
proud to be associated with it and with
that i like to present mark Shriver two
years old thank
good morning Thank You senator Dodd for
that kind introduction and for your
fantastic words as usual I think Bruce
summarized your role on Capitol Hill
over the last 36 years as the go-to guy
and I don't think there's a better way
of saying it Save the Children which is
headquartered in Westport Connecticut is
so proud that you represented us for so
many years in Washington DC but more
importantly represented all kids across
this country and really across the world
so thank you very much for coming thank
you Bruce four-point of us all together
the work of first focus is fantastic and
we're proud I'd say the children to be
associated with you jennifer has been an
artist's ambassador for our us programs
for four years we met when she was
pregnant about to give birth to her
second child and she has been a
relentless fierce advocate on behalf of
America's kids for the last four years
and has done an amazing job we were
together last week in Seattle Washington
we went out and looked at our programs
in Lake Quinault about an hour outside
of Seattle she has been to our programs
all across the country California
Seattle or Washington State West
Virginia where we actually started our
programs as a result of her advocacy wit
now senator Manchin but then governor
Manchin and has been absolutely
fantastic I get to introduce senator
Casey so I'm going to hold off saying
nice things about you for a couple of
minutes that's okay right yeah okay all
right just a couple quick words as the
senator mentioned about Save the
Children we are working well known for
our work internationally in about 130
countries around the world here in the
United States where we started almost 80
years ago as a program focused in
Kentucky helping kids affected by the
depression we're now working in over 200
schools with our in school after school
and summer literacy programs in about
130 140 communities on our early steps
to school success program which is a
home visiting program for young kids and
their parents ages zero to five and the
results are fantastic and it's enabled
us to grow over the last six or seven
years and particularly since the Great
Recession
and because the results are clear
they're demonstrative they are showing
that kids when they start at the
programmer at certain levels and by the
end year later have made strides in
their reading almost doubling the number
of kids reading at grade level and I'm
seventy percent of the kids are showing
statistically relevant changes in their
reading skills which is a fantastic
number particularly given the number of
kids that are entering the program not
prepared to learn Bruce mentioned the
status of kids in this country today 16
million kids almost twenty-two percent
of the kids in this country living in
poverty and for those kids under the age
of five the poverty rates are even worse
almost twenty-five percent of the kids
under the age of five are living in
poverty and for many of those kids
they're living in extreme poverty and as
many of you know but I think it's worth
repeating to the press those first five
years of life are crucial almost ninety
percent of brain growth happens in those
first five years of life yet public
investment is Senator Dodd just
mentioned are almost flat until a kid
enters kindergarten and when you show
that chart to businessmen and
businesswomen around the country they
see it brain growth first five years of
life public investment almost flat until
the first five years of life it's a huge
lost opportunity so what we want to talk
about is why as a country we're not
making that investment and if we look
historically we can see that in in the
mid-1960s the poverty rates for kids and
seniors were just about the same as they
are for kids today about twenty-five
percent of the kids and seniors living
in poverty in 1965 my father Sargent
Shriver started the war on poverty under
President Johnson at that point in time
within ten years those rates had both
dropped down to fifteen percent and the
senior rate has continued to drop today
to today it's at its lowest rate ever
nine percent whereas kids the poverty
rate for children has continued
unfortunately to go to go back up to
where it is today at almost twenty-three
twenty-four percent and as Senator Dodd
eloquently said the reason for that I
think is pretty clear kids don't vote
they don't have political action
campaigns they're not on television they
don't have a strong enough voice here in
wash
in DC and I think that that is
absolutely an issue that we have to
address I just want to talk very quickly
about one of the issues that's in the
report it's early childhood education
and a Senator Dodd said we've made great
progress over the last four years the
home visitation program for new and
expecting moms that live in high risk
communities was part of the Affordable
Care Act the senator mentioned the race
to the top funding five hundred million
dollars in in 2011 and an additional 133
million dollars for the top five
runner-up States in 2012 but the facts
remain even though that is good news
that less than five percent of the kids
that are eligible for early headstart
are getting early head start services in
this country today and depending on your
number but in our report we show that
less than thirty percent of the kids
that are eligible for headstart are
getting those services today there's no
question that the quality needs to go up
in both of those efforts say the
children is now running head start
programs in Arkansas and will soon be in
Louisiana to try to improve the quality
of services delivered by those programs
and we need to do a better job in making
sure that child care dollars are spent
more efficiently and more effectively
having an impact on kids but the bottom
line remains that we should not be
talking about whether to get those
programs but we should be talking about
making additional investments to make
more eligible kids get those services
and to increase the quality of the
services that are going out there and
it's not just me saying that or first
focus and save the children there are
countless other entities the center for
american progress is said that by 2020
china one of our biggest competitors
plans to enroll 40 million children in
preschool which is a fifty percent
increase from today and provide seventy
percent of children with three years of
preschool united states has no national
plan and no efforts are no plans to
invest additional dollars in early
childhood education that is outrageous
Ben Bernanke has called for an increased
investment in early childhood education
saying the payoffs of early childhood
programs can be especially high Prince
preschool programs for disadvantaged
children have been shown to increase
high school graduation rates because
high school graduates have higher
earnings pay more taxes and are less
likely to use public health programs
investing in such programs can pay off
even from the narrow perspective of
state budgets of course the returns to
the overall economy to the individuals
themselves are much greater James
Heckman the Nobel Prize winner out of
the University of Chicago which is no
flaming liberal organization has said
that the most important investment we
can make is an early childhood education
as Bruce said we're not great in
Congress we're not grading the
administration we're not grading any
particular institution with this report
but we are calling upon all Americans to
make and to demand more investment from
our leaders both on the state federal
and local level senator Dodd said a
great that we do as a country believe
that children are our most important
resource but the bottom line is we don't
do it we don't invest in our kids so
despite the fact that many political
leaders say that kids are most important
resource we don't as a country put our
money where our mouth is and that's
national tragedy and it's a national
shame and we're hoping that this report
will highlight some of the areas that we
should be investing our dollars and
should not just be bobbing our heads
like bobblehead dolls saying kids are a
most important resource and then do
nothing about it we've been playing that
game for too long one of the guys who
does not play that game on Capitol Hill
is Senator Casey senator dodd talked
about his great work on the help
committee my uncle often talked about
the great work that Senator Casey was
engaged in he's been one of the stalwart
advocates for the Children's Health
Insurance Program he's been a strong
strong supporter of the 21st century fun
program that supports efforts like say
the children's work in rural America all
across the country he has joined
Jennifer senator Mikulski and others to
introduce early childhood legislation
that unfortunately has not passed it's
because we have not garnered the
bipartisan support and made early
childhood education
the priority that this country needs but
Senator Casey has introduced that
legislation has pushed for it and we're
hopeful that when he gets reelected this
fall that will go back up to Capitol
Hill and continue that push forward
Senator Bob Casey thank you very much
mark thank you and save the children for
this report and for your great work over
so many years we're grateful to work
with organizations like Save the
Children and first focus Bruce thank you
for your great work and for getting a
report done you know when Senator Dodd
and I were talking about having this
report done a couple of years ago once a
while in Washington when he asked for a
report you actually get it so we're
grateful for that and chris dodd i'm so
happy to see you again I chacras not too
long ago but so grateful for a grateful
for your work in your leadership in the
voice that he brings to these issues and
it's more than a voice of passion and
commitment that's vitally important you
have to you have to have a heart and a
commitment but he's got a long record of
achievement substantial achievement and
as you're recalling some of that work
going on the road literally to make sure
that you made children our priority and
I think senator Dodd reminds us again
that meeting the challenge is outlined
in this report can't be one party it has
to be bipartisan and it has to be public
and private not one entity not one part
of our society can do this alone and by
reciting some of that history it reminds
us and I think it challenges us to do
all we can to bring the parties together
so we're so grateful and Jennifer thank
you for your great leadership I've been
introducing Jennifer in a couple of
minutes I just wanted to make a couple
of points about the report this report
provides a report card but I think in
large measure provides a measure of
accountability and it's a it's a mirror
into which we don't look often enough to
reflect upon where we are the commitment
that we make to our kids
always said that what what brings people
in this room together no matter who you
are what brings you in this room is a
basic belief that every child is born
with the light inside them for some
children that light is is so magnificent
they don't need a lot of help because of
the circumstances are because of their
their natural ability but for some kids
they need an extra help that might be
early education that might be helped
that their family can provide with
health care whatever it is and we've got
to make sure and I think it's the
obligation of every public official
every elected official at every level in
appointed officials to do all that you
can to make sure that the full measure
of that light inside every child is
reached no matter what the full measure
of that potential is and we got a ways
to go before we can say we're doing that
we've made some great progress under the
leadership of Senator Dodd and others
but we've got a long way to go on the
public side of this I think the private
sector is going to help us as well and I
think both parties have an obligation it
was a great line somewhere in the
scriptures about a faithful friend and
you've heard this line before a faithful
friend is a sturdy shelter he who has
found one has found a treasure and I
think when you see the results of a
report like this whether it's a c-minus
or a C or even a be until we get to a I
think we're going to be asking whether
or not we are the faithful friend the
children that we should be that I think
we have to be in order to compete in an
internationally difficult and
challenging economy but also I think to
ask ourselves isn't it what we should be
doing as a nation a report like this
allows us to measure where we are and
also to provide a road map so that we
can move forward in the future so I
think one of the things we can do here
in Washington both parties is to commit
ourselves to being a really committed
and authentic faithful friend to our
children in one of the ways that we do
that is not simply by focusing on the
public policy the bills of legislation
of the public policy work but also by
partnering with people well beyond
Washington who can bring their voice who
can bring their passion and their
commitment to an issue like this and
Jennifer Garner has done that in so many
ways we know where is an actress and an
artist first and foremost that's where
most of us became aware of her work but
I know her as an advocate she's a mom
too and we got a letter today that it
indicates the commitment of her whole
family to these issues that she might
she might read for us but I'm so
grateful for her work as an advocate
someone who brings an articulate voice a
voice of passion but also a voice of
real commitment to making sure that the
grades on this report card go up and
that will be the faithful friend to our
children that we should be so I'm
honored to introduce someone who's done
a lot of work over over many years now
on these issues Jennifer Garner
thank you so much thank you for your
kind words Senator Casey and for having
me here today I did bring a letter along
um you know kids do not love but when I
my kids and I'm sure yours too when I
leave town but my my kids really know
that when I leave town for save the
children I do it with joy and with a
sense of purpose and I try to help them
understand and help them include them in
that sense of purpose and last night no
the night before when I was telling my
my six-year-old I'm going to be gone
I'll be back the next night you know
this is what I'm doing I'm going to
speak with some senators and then I
happen to be speaking at the CIA later
today and she she disappeared for a bit
and came back with the letter she wrote
absolutely on her own and it says I'm
dear senators and CIA and then please
give my mom the money she wants for save
the children it is a really good cause I
appreciate the time you've taken on my
letter sincerely violin effort so so
there's one person that we've got this
one taken care of she understands good
okay we just have a few other hundreds
of millions um so I am thrilled to be
here in the midst of people who are
committed to strengthening our country's
commitment to our kids and I'm
particularly honored to have senator
Dodd with US senator Dodd as I've said
before I don't think we could have asked
for a stronger advocate for our nation's
children I walked into a party that you
had already set up for me I have no
doubt that when pundits and historians
debate the legacy of your service they
will all agree on your dedication to
children particularly children living in
poverty it's unparalleled and I cannot
thank you enough for your leadership
I also want to thank you for passing the
torch to our great friends from the
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania senator
Casey since arriving in Washington DC in
2006 senator Casey has become one of the
fiercest child advocates in Congress
he's been a staunch supporter of early
childhood education which is my favorite
issue and it has been a privilege
working with you of the past few years
so thank you as Senator Casey mentioned
I'm an artist ambassador for Save the
Children's us programs I met mark
Shriver we r do oh hi about four years
ago and from our first conversation I
knew that save the children was the
place for me you see I grew up in West
Virginia and have seen firsthand the
effects of poverty that dyed-in-the-wool
kind of resigned to help helplessness
poverty that permeates many of the
Forgotten communities that mark and his
team serve just last week mark and i
visited the quinault nation in western
Washington it is so beautiful up there
it's right on the Pacific coast it's on
the edge of the Olympic National Park
it's breathtaking and families are
living in these dilapidated trailers
with no heat except for a wood-burning
stove in the middle as their only source
of heat and the children running around
and coming very dangerously close I mean
anyone who has a kid walking in front of
even your oven you say oh watch out
watch out it's hot so with a big hot
stove in the middle it's no surprise
that we met a little boy with burned
blisters all over his hands because it's
a tiny little trailer and he bumped up
against it and his hands were burned of
course there were no books or toys
anywhere inside except for those brought
by saved the children and I wish that I
could say this was the exception but the
more I travel with Mark and save the
children the more I see that this is far
too familiar all over the country this
story for kids and for too many kids in
this country is tragically simple we are
not preparing them for school half of
the children in the United States get no
true early childhood education and kids
living in poverty have heard on average
30 million fewer words spoken to them by
the time they're four years old our kids
are falling behind
four year olds from families living in
poverty at four years old they're 18
months behind developmentally I met a
little boy last week who was 17 months
old and he was about where my 7 month
old is developmentally and that really
isn't an exaggeration and my 7 month old
is not a genius he's just a baby but
he's babbling and he's curious and he's
engaging in the way that all of your
babies do and this 17 month old was just
starting to get there it's shocking it's
shocking to see as a result America is
falling behind the story is is not a new
one especially to those of you in the
room who advocate for kids each and
every day you know this all too well you
also know that we need leaders and no
one has been a stronger voice for
children than chris dodd prior his
departure from Congress senator dodd
called upon save the children and first
focus to evaluate and grade the country
on key issues affecting children
including education health and economic
stability after nearly two years of
research and evaluation these
organizations produced an excellent
piece of work and as you will soon see
this report card shows that we the
wealthiest nation in the world are not
meeting our obligations to the future
there's so much work that's needed and
at times it seems overwhelming it's even
kind of depressing it's it's not great
news but there is hope there is hope
over the last few years under the
leadership of both senators dad and
Casey the Obama administration and
Congress have provided new key
investments in early learning and
children's health programs including the
five hundred million dollars for the
race to the top early learning challenge
fund the over three billion dollars in
new Early Head Start and Early Early
Head Start Early Head Start and Head
Start funding and nearly thirty three
billion dollars in new funds for the
Children's Health Insurance Program
which also expanded coverage to four
million new children simply put strong
investments in education and health for
the next generation are essential to
ensuring the economic prosperity and
security of America and deeper
investments particularly in early
childhood education means something very
personal to me and not just because I
have
about 50 little kids at my house um at
least that's what it feels like these
investments are fundamental to breaking
the cycle of poverty in places like Poe
not Washington in places like my home
state in west of west virginia actually
all over the country where poverty has
gripped families for generations today
nearly one in four children lives in
poverty in America inequality is the
highest it's been in a generation and
now more than ever children need strong
dedicated advocates like you to be their
voice and that's why I'm proud to be
here today with mark and Bruce our
friends from the Senate and all of you
to unveil this crucial report to me it
isn't just about investing it's about
making America and even stronger more
competitive and more just nation that is
to me the most important action we can
undertake thank you very much
I just I'll take a second all right all
right so I'm going to walk through some
of the findings in the report pretty
quickly and then we'll take some
questions so first first first of all
what we did was we broke the report into
five domains and so what we have here is
economic security early childhood k-12
education permanence and stability and
health and safety these areas were
chosen because they provide the
strongest indicators of child well-being
within each of the five primary areas of
child well-being they're more specific
categories and you can find those in the
report there what we in in doing the
report i'll give you real quickly that
there were some great resources that we
used mounted already tracked the
well-being of children including the
Annie E casey foundations Kids Count
data book the foundation for child of
elements child well-being index and the
Children's Defense funds the state of
America's children series this report
complements these existing resources
while we use many of the same reliable
and objective data as these other
materials America's report card is
unique because it assigns grades for
each aspect of child well-being and
overall grade of how children are faring
in the United States I also just wanted
to briefly thank also the advisory board
so these are people who or national
export spurts that we called in and you
can see there we cited them in the
report and they were very helpful in us
thinking about and really finding the
best indicators and and if you are here
can you please just stand up briefly on
the Dennises here and else in America I
yeah thank you both so very much
so I was Dennis Johnson from the
chillins help fund and mary kessler from
the National Education Association who
also just had had a new baby so so let's
see so so what we have here is sort of a
mixed bag and people talked about that
and so in some indicators were doing
very well by kids right so we talked
about we are we are very close to the
finish line on on children's health
coverage and with with the work between
Medicaid passager that Jones health
insurance program and the extension of
the children's health insurance program
we have less than ten percent of our
nation's kids lack health insurance
today a profound improvement in other
areas we're making strides and people
talked about so the race to the top fund
some the efforts on early childhood
where we've made some enormous strides
but still have a ways to go and then in
other areas we we feel strongly that
we're really failing to prioritize kids
and have a lot of work to do so lots of
if you think about in terms of we're in
football season kind of some places
we're near the finish line some places
were kind of in midfield in some places
we are we're just starting starting out
and so so one thing I want to decide is
we also we did a poll recently with
public opinion strategies which is a
Republican polling firm and we asked we
asked the American public to what is
what do you what do you all think how
children are faring and what we found
was some some interesting data with
respect to kids one is is that the
American public almost by a three-to-one
margin believe that in the last ten
years the lives of kids have have have
gotten worse and they also don't are not
confident that this generation of kids
will not fare better than this the
current generation and so I think we're
that sort of a unique point in history
in our in our country is that we we've
profoundly in this country believe in
the American Dream which is that every
generation builds off the past
generation and for a majority of
Americans today that that belief and
that that that the next generation will
do better is being shaken so we I think
that the American public has spoken on
this an hour pro-family
concerned about the well-being of kids
in the next generation so on the area of
Economic Security we talked a little bit
we talked about this um so we have
twenty two percent of our nation's kids
so more than one in five are living in
poverty 8.5 million kids are living in
feud insecure homes there's 1 million
kids in their country who are homeless
and but there are some some positives
and so we do know that the earned income
tax credit in the child tax credit for
example lift five million children out
of poverty and so those programs are key
to making sure that this problem does
not get worse and and something to note
is that in this some of these per the
earning can tax cut credit and the child
tax credit or actually have for
extension at the end of this year so so
things are definitely you know appearing
at right now in front of us that we need
to work on immediately with respect to
challenge senior poverty rates i think
there's also a lesson in sidered dodge
spoke to this and so did jennifer garner
about the child poverty ray and what we
need to do about this I mean what you
can see is that in 1966 the poverty rate
for seniors was much higher than that
for kids and with focused with a lot of
focus and a lot of the work of Mark and
Mark Shrivers a dad and and other people
we have tackled some of these problems
and you can see the the poverty rate for
seniors and Mark talked a lot about this
about is now down to nine percent but
the problem area for kids is going back
up and so what we're calling on is is
sort of a focus a focus particularly on
child poverty and Great Britain the
Blair administration in 1999 decided to
tackle child poverty rates and you can
see that they're probably right when he
he just this Union was much higher than
the United States and you can see that
it's fallen the other thing that's
interesting about this is if you go
forward if you go this runs through only
to 2007 but if you go forward yet we
know that the poverty rate for in the
United States actually has gone up to
twenty-two twenty-three percent but the
poverty rate for the UK is still down at
12
so probably right today in the UK is
about half that of the United States
despite having started off with a higher
rate so it can be done I'm on early
childhood I won't talk too much about
this because um there's awesome speakers
about this before me talk about this but
I'm just a highlight a few things Head
Start reaches less than a third of
eligible kids Early Head Start only
reaches four-point-five percent of our
nation's kids and child care funding
reaches only one in six of eligible
parents so we have that we have the
systems in place we have not provided
the adequate resources to get kids where
they need to be in education look my
kids go to some of the best public
schools in America my parents are both
former teachers and i think that the
American education system is in places
is incredibly strong and needs to be
supported but what we know is that
there's still racial disparities that we
need to work on we have enormous
differences in how we fund schools in
this country it's like if you look in
Texas for example there's like a three
to four to one ratio and what the
highest and the wealthiest schools and
that's they get and what the poorest
schools get we also know that
forty-three percent of title one schools
are still unfunded and one in six
americans aged 16-24 not in score
working I will note that we are failing
kids if in Texas Texas has for example
over the last decade the growth in the
number of kids in this country Texas has
fifty percent of that and what it Texas
to last year's they cut education
spending by over five billion dollars
and so my parents live in Texas so I
know this um I'm schools in texas have
40 / 40 kids in the classroom and that
that's not a success their school's
systems who have completely eliminated
extracurricular activities no sports no
debate no drama no art clubs with
because of the lack of funding and and
that's something as a nation we must we
must address um I won't go into this
for lack of time but you can see we
still have disparities in dropout rates
that we must work on although this is a
success story in that those numbers are
declining so we are moving in the right
direction I'm permanence and stability
permanence and stability sort of
combines the issues of child welfare
child abuse and neglect immigration
policy and also juvenile justice and so
what we know for example is that there's
over there's almost 6,000 kids in this
country who are held in adult gels which
is a completely inappropriate setting
for children we know that there's no
support in forty percent of
substantiated child abuse cases and we
know that 26,000 kids annually aged out
of foster care without families and the
numbers on kind of how they fare is very
poor and so one of the things we really
need to move to in a nation is we're
working on we're making some success in
terms of stability of kids in the foster
care system but we really need to move
to that next step of sort of a measure
of child well-being because we need to
care not only that the children are safe
we need to care about their outcomes we
need to care about their housing their
health their education and in terms of
immigration one of the things that's a
problem that that is I really didn't
have a great sense of on and some of our
staff have worked really really
tirelessly on is the issue of how
immigration policy foreign policy and
child welfare policy don't work together
and so we may have we have an
immigration policy where we do removal
of parents but sometimes neglecting what
happens to the kids there's a report
that came out that over a hundred
thousand parents had been deported at
some point we have no idea what happens
to the children in those country that
and so that's that's an issue that that
we really we really need to pay
attention to in tackle so so again and
one issue that positive story is that
the number of kids in foster care is
declining so we are doing a better job
of trying to get it get the issues for
kids early and again we need to really
move to this more comprehensive measure
of child well-being when it comes to
child welfare issues
last and this is this is sort of a good
news bad news story in and of itself so
health and safety so one of the great
things enormous success story again is
this the issue the passage of the
Children's Health Insurance Program and
the decline in the number of uninsured
kids in this country we did it we did a
focus group in Nevada and we asked
people this question this is a story the
American public doesn't yet untry alino
we asked people in that focus group what
how many what percentage of kids do you
think are insured unless in every single
person that focus group thought less
than sixty percent of the kids weren't
you know in this nation had a health
insurance but the fact the matter is
that real number is over ninety percent
and so we've done we've done a success
this is an enormous success story and
that story is not understood well by the
American public on the other hand access
access problems mean coverage don't
always translate to care and we know
that so a lot of work to do in terms of
access to care and again Dennis Johnson
who was from children's health fund it's
something they work tirelessly on in
terms of trying to improve both not only
the coverage but the access to care we
also know we made public health progress
with immunization rates and and things
like that in this country one area that
that is also a little bit of a problem
well back to the public health issue we
also know that there's a child childhood
obesity epidemic in this country so for
a mixed story there in sort of public
health and then on the environmental
health side we know about the asthma
issues in this country and that's really
highlighted in the report about those
issues so again here's the story of the
passage of the choice health insurance
program in 1997 and kind of the the
major decline in the number of uninsured
kids in this country so last back to the
poll we asked we also we know that for
example in the percentage of the budget
so kids represent a quarter of the
population at but yet we only represent
about eight percent of the federal
budget so we asked the public what
percentage of the budget do you think
that that kids should get and what voter
said was that it should be twenty eight
percent so the American public believes
that kids should get about their their
share of the population if not a little
more
instead what we have is a enormous gap
and last we asked voters a question
about do you think that candidates for
office should pay more attention or less
attention to children and what and
almost two-thirds said that they believe
that we should be paying more attention
and also eighty-two percent of voters
said that this is the issue of kids and
how candidates address them will make a
difference in their vote so how do we
how do we address this um one thing is
sort of rake ticking you to raise
awareness around these issues and we've
been working with save the children and
others on on sort of a social media
strategy even around awareness and and
so hashtags we're using only going on
like Twitter like if kids 2012 and talk
poverty but also the center dogs spoke
to this about holding and Marshall ever
talked about this is holding
policymakers accountable so we need to
ask them the questions I hope that in
these debates someone asked the question
about how kids are faring in this
country and then exactly as he said no
matter who wins or loses we need to hold
policymakers accountable and continue to
get these issues in front of people and
all of you in the room I know I see many
familiar people who do exactly that and
we need to continue to build this set of
people across the country to really keep
this issue first and foremost in
people's mind so getting involved you
can download the report on our website
and also I believe also on the Save the
Children website and also just one quick
shout out I we're going to thank a
shoddy who Shire care about Darin Kevin
Lindsey for all the work hours and hours
and hours and hours of work on this and
Jessica Newman as well for doing all the
research on this and talking to many of
you out there on on these issues and
again our advisory board and all the
peoples staff at save the children for
for all their work on this as well so
thank you at this point I think we're
happy to take some questions from the
audience and it's going to come up and
no I guess the only the only last point
that I would make Bruce that I forgot to
make is Senator Dodd just whispered it
in my ear is that there in the last
presidential debate was not one question
on poverty and I just think again as the
vice presidential debate happened and
the president in the next two
presidential debates we ought to have at
least one question on kids in poverty in
this country and I hope that the hashtag
booths just put out there will help
folks at home or anybody in this room
try to get that message out because it's
really a national disgrace that we have
almost twenty-five percent of the kids
in this country living in poverty and it
never is discussed in the presidential
campaigns any questions yes
let me just say in terms of the in terms
of sequestration and what we're facing
one of the messages I think from both
parties is that we've got to come
together to get an agreement that avoids
the the imposition of sequestration
because it's bites by definition it's an
arbitrary across-the-board cut which
would be devastating for the economy in
in defense programs and and non-defense
and I think that message is starting to
get out and I think we'll get we'll get
an agreement to avoid that but in the
process of doing that we have to
identify priorities we have to identify
values now fortunately in the the
agreement in 2011 there were programs
exempted like Medicaid and that was the
right decision but even even with
certain exemptions we've got to make
sure that first and foremost we avoid
the imposition of sequestration but
beyond that we're going to have some
difficult debates about what happens
after that when we start to deal with
the larger debt issues but I think we
can avoid in a bipartisan way the impact
of sequestration and that of course
would be good for the economy but it
would also be good for kids
I'm so so on the UH net also want to
point out where that what the public
thinks about this so we asked this
question of the public about do you
think the deficit is in or is it concern
of yours and ninety-one percent of
americans said yes is absolutely concern
and so all we said is what are your
priorities then so we asked a series of
questions about what would you cut and
what do you think is eligible you know
it should be elsewhere for cuts well
I'll say one of the great things about
this poll was that the American public
say this is about basically you know
what they come out with is this is about
priorities and choices and so when asked
you care about the deficit do you think
that education early childhood childcare
head start Jones health insurance
program Medicaid student loans child
abuse and neglect funding prevention
funding do you think those things should
be cut and on every single question
overwhelmingly the American public said
not on kids not on the backs of kids and
so so yes we should tackle the deficit
and actually the deficit can be seen
very much so as a children's issue
because they will be paying back but the
fact is people believe that we need to
be making investments so that that
generation is strong and can fulfill
their god-given potential and so very
strong and it's bipartisan Democrats
Republicans unanimously believe that
I'll also point out that we even ask
people who are tea party supporters so
you might think here's a group that
might not be with us on five of the
seven measures they the vast majority of
tea party supporters oppose cutting
children's programs so to areas where we
need to do a little work on with them is
on head start and student loans but on
child health Medicaid other issues they
opposed making cuts to children's
programs the other questions
yes morning I'm bill O'Hare with the
ante casey foundation used to work on
the kids count project but so i have a
special place in my heart for any report
that has data in it and i appreciate
your efforts in nice to see the report
actually have a two-part question if I
could what is any plans about
replicating this in the future in terms
of reducing it yearly by yearly well
thinking like they really think would be
helpful in the accountability aspect and
secondly any plans to take the report
card down to the state or even local
level um I would say I mean we're still
talking about that I'm I mean it is a
lot of it is a lot of work and so we're
trying to figure out we'd like to do it
do it again shortly and certainly think
about doing state by state level but you
know one of the things that's really
great as any casey Foundation I know
you've really let a lot so much of that
work it on kids count does do that and
so trying to really figure out how this
really fits in with that is important
but we do believe this is an important
yardstick using those those data sources
and and all the work that has already
been done so we don't intend to replica
you know to duplicate we tend to be
additive and sort of thinking through
that and look to working with any of you
in this room about how what's best in
doing so well I would hope it would be I
just again I'm a personal level I think
the value of this is that you you know
we all grew up in communities and know
how important it is for a community to
to know how they're doing you'll the old
thermometer in town just to be I guess a
gray hair those new it look like you
might remember as well the thermometer
in town in the chamber of commerce in
the community would run that that big
thermometer and whatever the community
goal was that year you could drive by it
every day and they be moving that red
line up further further getting closer
to our goals and I think it's so
important that we have a template by
which to make judgments we have
conferences like this and reports each
year and it go glaze the eyes over I've
even most determined listener if you
don't have some standard by which we
judge how we're doing as I said earlier
we do it on almost
everything else I got we get weather
reports every day tell us how we're
doing why can't we find some way to
measure how our children are doing and
so we have some sense on a yearly or
biannually basis of judging how we doing
in these issues how our children's
health issues being addressed on
education on their security and the like
so we have a way of measuring that and
giving the opportunity to those at the
local state and national level to be
able to respond to those what are the
priorities ought to be we're doing
better on some of these issues I think
that's so important in a debate for
people not only the policy setters but
the general public to be able to
understand how we're doing as a nation
when it comes to this critical issue so
again I know this these are big
decisions to make and resources are
scarce but if you if you really want to
get behind something that's worthwhile I
believe having this kind of a
measurement on some regular with some
regularity I think would be a great
asset in terms of moving the ball
forward on all the issues that we talked
about year in year out so forever it's
worth that's just an advocate go ahead
turn me down hello I'm read Mackey with
the child labor coalition and I just
wanted to mention that there is a pocket
of vulnerable children called migrant
farmworker children who work 12 hour
days sometimes in 100-degree heat at
grave peril and it really hampers their
education I want to thank Bruce for his
leadership in helping this population
and I just um we could really use some
help in Congress to equalize the child
labor laws in the US so that these kids
are not discriminated against so if
anybody has any comments on how we could
help this particular population of you
know largely immigrant kids but not
exclusively that'd be great thank you
on the onion chopped liver right that's
definitely an issue that we are focused
on our first focus and in the and we
talked a little bit about it in the
report and absolutely and again I think
one of the key things i think this
report really highlights and really
reinforced for us is the issues for kids
are not sec you know very sector like we
don't we can't just care about it kids
education we have to care about their
health care and there and that's it
exactly as you said for these kids
they're working in in conditions that we
need to we need to address it with
respect to our child labor laws we also
need to make sure that the education and
health care issues for those kids are
addressed appropriately many of them are
uninsured some have different
immigration status and immigration also
plays into this so a lot of different
issues that we really need to think
about as a country and make sure we're
dealing with the whole child and their
whole well-being not just you know on
the very specific sectors but huge issue
that that deserves more attention
good morning I'm Marty share I'm with
the campaign for us ratification of the
crc Convention on the Rights of the
Child and I know that we have the number
of active long-term supporters of it
here what I i see this report as
dovetailing beautifully with the unicef
report on state of the world's children
what really concerns me is something
that was mentioned earlier and that is
where we stand in face of the rest of
the world and that's it it kind of
speaks to our credibility as a nation
when we try to talk about how wonderful
the United States is and I just wonder
one on if anyone would make any comment
on the crc and two on whether whether
this really matters whether where we
stand and face the rest of the world is
something that this is aimed at helping
with thanks mark i think to the the last
question you asked is does this really
matter i think the answer is yes I don't
know how it can't matter i think that
you know it when I'm listening to Bruce
talked about the public opinion you talk
about the numbers of folks that are in
favor of investing in kids and yet our
political leadership doesn't do anything
about it really begs the question why
not I mean the answer to your question
is emphatically yes but the problem is
that we don't somehow have enough
political Jews frankly those of us who
are advocates in this room and have been
pushing the issue we don't have enough
political juice to get through to the
political leadership in this country or
in many states and that's the situation
we're in I mean lets you got to call a
spade a spade here so I think we've got
to get involved in the political process
I mean democracy is messy and the
squeaky wheel gets greased as we often
hear when I'm out in state governments
in the bottom line is we you know folks
it got to raise money and they got to
get politically engaged and they've got
to get folk that you know poor people
engage in this process or else we're not
going to make any product
on on any of these issues and it is too
it can be really discouraging at times
it can also be encouraging because we've
made progress but we need to do more and
to do better because kids just don't
have the resources to get that message
out young Jamie pavlovsky with the
American Academy of Pediatrics thank you
all for the good work that you do on
behalf of our nation's children a couple
of questions vendo speak on behalf of a
lot of other advocacy organizations and
groups in the room of folks that care
for children so if there are one or two
things that you could recommend senators
or Bruce or anyone on the stage of what
we can do between now and the election
to help take the good compelling call to
action data in this report and influence
Congress on sequestration cuts looming
and other issues that policy wise are
tied to some of the data in this report
I will have to take that charge back to
the nation's pediatricians and secondly
i have here with me aap Charlie the
child health advocate it's a flat family
type of campaign that were undertaking
with you now in the election to
represent that although the children
can't vote they have a voice to all of
us and I love also you're willing to get
a photo that we can share with all of
you and our little a few Chartley figure
before the end of that's my shameless
plug
a very good question let me not by way
of a recommendation because I don't want
to tie head how to do your work as an
advocate you you know how to do it but I
do think in the context of an election
but even even beyond the election but
maybe especially because candidates are
asked questions and in are held to
account this is an ideal time to raise
these issues number one number two is at
least from my vantage point when I look
at my home state of Pennsylvania we we
made great advancements in the 1990s on
children's health insurance made
tremendous advancements later on early
education but it couldn't just simply be
a public policy or elected officials
priority the reason why we made progress
is because there were those partnerships
one of the most significant partnerships
that would develop there and i think
around the country and first focus and
save the children could speak to this
more directly as the business community
some of the most passionate advocates
for investing in early learning
investing in children's health insurance
our business leaders and not just a
couple but but CEO after CEO saying that
they understand the grit not just the
gravity of the problem but also what it
means for the the economic bottom line
so the more that we can link this
appropriately to jobs in the economy and
future economic growth the better
because that engages a lot of folks who
may not may not as part of their daily
work be a child advocate or be an
advocate for one or the other issue but
linking it to economic growth gross
national product whatever whatever
measuring wherever measurement news
about the economy and i think more and
more that's happening and ceos i think
in the last at least of my my experience
in the last 15 years have become the one
of the greatest champions of this
Ross Brenneman education week I was
wondering even as students or children
can't vote and get engaged on perhaps a
policy level how in your work have you
seen students be engaged in in dealing
with these issues at all especially
maybe miss carner as well I don't
understand quick how have you seen
students and children being engaged and
kind of combating these issues that are
affecting them well kids growing up in
poverty don't necessarily know that they
are by the time they hit school they're
already so far behind that they're
starting off on their heels instead of
forward and they're starting off with
without pride and without excitement and
with in kindergarten when you see kids
who are ashamed and scared to be there
that is a problem they don't know many
of them have never held a book before so
they don't know how to turn the pages
they don't know what print is they you
know there's one book for every 13 kids
in these communities instead of on
average for our kids you know 13 books
for kids for each child mm so how to get
kids involved or how they are involved
is just by being there for them and
giving them the leg up that they need
and kids growing up in a more prosperous
households I don't know how you know how
we involve them that's not something
that I've worked on I think I think you
know if you look at the example of the
recycling movement in this country that
started really from schools and kids you
know essentially shaming their parents
and to do in recycling
call again call a spade a spade you know
and you see that that happens on that
issue so if you're writing an education
week and you can get teachers to get
their kids their classrooms engaged you
see so much on change.org you see the
impact on the lorax the film you know
started because kids got involved and
wanted that message of environmentalism
incorporated in the film so there are a
number of examples of change happening
from from kids pulling their parents
forward and I think you know if you can
encourage teachers principals school
systems to get their kids to understand
that almost one in four kids in this
country lives in poverty that's a pretty
stunning statistic and I bet you if that
get message gets out which is a great
way to do it through EDD week is to get
that message out that kids want to do
something about it whether it's adopting
a school whether it's doing a book drive
whether it's doing a money drive for
schools you know kids are doing that
type of stuff all across the country but
you know to answer one of the questions
earlier we don't have a big enough
platform to get that message out we
don't speak Save the Children first
focus don't speak to thousands of school
teachers in the country so you ought to
tell them that there's one almost one in
four kids live in poverty and you know
through your publication challenged them
to get involved just like businesses are
doing including PNC in Pennsylvania on
the early education issue that's a
different person Jim more leading that
charge then you know somebody and like
me who's kind of a normal advocate if
you will but if you have a businessman
or kids leading the charge politicians
listen to children right yeah so it's a
good photo op to be with kids so why
don't you get those kids that are
teachers to read education week and you
guys put down challenge on yeah
the grants we had time for one more
question yet lucky me i guess my name is
tina mccarter and I'm with the US
Department of Labor's office of child
labor force labor and human trafficking
and so with picking up on the child
labor issue sirkali greed they're
focused on both international and
national child labor we focus more on
international my question is actually a
little different it's a bit technical we
this year for the first time we publish
an annual report but for the first time
we actually tried to assess how other
governments are doing in combating child
labor so I'm very curious to know a
little bit more about how you came up
with the grade and the grading system in
the report card and I guess a specific
question that I had was you had sort of
various indicators did you wait each of
those sort of similarly and then what
was your process for coming up with the
sort of the final grade thank you um so
so what we did is first focus and save
the children we first of all we use it
sort of the base the report that sir
Dodd put out in 2010 so and and use an E
casey found foundation Kids Count data
and the Chinese for child development
child well-being index and other
measures and also you know from the
various agencies their data as well and
so looking at that as a base we also
looked at the unicef numbers and looked
at sort of try to do as much as possible
it's very difficult to do cross-country
comparisons and then based on that
really think about what you know kind of
looking at kind of the way the UK did
right so they developed a child poverty
target and they said we should be able
to cut the child poverty rate in half in
10 years and they succeeded they did
succeeded this and so so thinking about
that where should we be and so is it
okay is there god pointed out that we're
29th in the world in infant mortality I
don't think there's a single person here
that would think that is okay and so as
we kind of looked at those kinds of
measures and thought about those things
and words with our advisory committee I
mean one of the things we really did
rely on them a lot about
you know what is the data what is that
saying and where should we be as a
nation that was sort of the yardstick we
measured and so that's thus we gave me
very poor grade on infant mortality and
how we're fairing is a country by kids
on the other hand the the numbers on on
children's health insurance coverage
we've made enormous progress and so we
gave an a-minus there were this close to
making sure that all kids in this
country have health insurance coverage
and in fact if you look at some of the
Persians the Affordable Care Act so
whether you think it like it or not some
of the provisions are very key for kids
coverage and so there was the extension
of the Jones health insurance program
that Senator Casey was a huge leader on
there was provisions around his mark
talked about the home visiting programs
there was there's express lane
eligibility to get technical but it
allows for data transfers between
programs so we can make sure that kids
who are eligible but not enrolled get
covered so a lot of those kinds of
things we felt like we were very close
there and so kind of doing a full
assessment and so in domains we then
came up with grades and then sort of
created an overall grade within the
domain and then for the overall grade
frankly it was just sort of a you know I
got you know how do we think we're doing
as a nation based on all this data that
we have and the feeling was you know
there's some good good things the middle
things but be particularly because of
the economic security and the issue that
twenty two percent of kids in this
country living in poverty and just the
profound feeling that that's not okay we
felt that you know I've sees sort of an
average we felt that at this point in
time we're not doing we're kind of near
an average but we could be doing a lot
better so C minus P so it became that it
was quite a bit consent it was a very
consensus process so again it's not
science the data underlying it is the
science but but it was it was really
trying to create a yardstick and the
great thing here is is forward it's an
easy thing to it's an easier thing to
measure right if we reduce the child
poverty rate or mad
they start movement you know then we're
talking about bees and you know other
great so so it's it's a yardstick at
center dot spoke thank you thank you all
thank you
here's